io non so se fare questo video ha un
senso
partiamo da un presupposto la parola che
quando io lo diceva pietro per scherzo
ci ho messo poi un sacco di tempo a
spiegare ai miei follower l'india voi
che stavo scherzando quando dicevo
pietre che ci è voluto del tempo ma con
il tempo io sono riuscito a togliere
l'etichetta di gay dalla parola pietro e
che vide mai farà pietro in questi
giorni
e allora c'è google plus lo sterco nel
cervello amico mio
detto questo ho sempre puntato la parola
game un aggettivo come un altro tipo
rosso alto è gay ma non come in sotto
quindi quando ai tempi c'erano gli
haters che i bambini poi tra l'altro
rischiano affari gay che vuol dire favi
rosso però non ho mai fatto un test per
capire quanto sono gay se son se anche
in una minima parte perché puoi essere
gay in una minima parte non sono gay
non mi piace la patata però credo di
avere delle sfumature c'è tipo bevo poca
birra non fumo mi piacciono i fini roma
c'è sono un po guardo i video di matte
business somma di rispondere su nature
gay un po cielo quindi volevo capire se
la mia è una chance sono convinto solo
io di questo se in realtà è così quindi
esistono questi dei test quanto sei gay
gioca che tipo di gelato preferisci cono
spaghetti gli spaghetti di gelato cosa
non sapevo neanche dell'esistenza di
questo aborto ghiacciolo coppa del nonno
coperta sorbetto calippo io faccio
questo the seriamente per come sembra se
serio giuro tra tutti questi se proprio
dovessi scegliere quello è coppetta come
beve un drink
l'importante che ci sia una cannuccia
sono un bicchiere nome i drink senza
ghiaccio poco alcol e molto frullato da
questo tipo di cucina ha preferito solo
italiano giapponese indiano messicano
vegano aj italiano solo sushi non
preferisco il giapponese all'italiano
per ora passa a furia di mangiarla tutti
i giorni un po mi ha dato la nausea
ultimamente quindi tra questi se dovessi
scegliere giapponese dai giapponesi in
generale non solo sushi qual è il tuo
colore preferito mio colore preferito è
il rosso quindi va bene che sarà una
vagina
ok mollusco se aiuto che fosse stato il
mio computer sta roba
cosa avete in questa foto una torta di
mele una conchiglia una vagina
l'ho visto subito petto di pollo una
lumaca una pesca sciroppata un calamaro
morale di maio salvini non vedo io vidi
una vagina subito l'ho vista cosa vedete
in questa foto una donna rifatta una
giornalista un pene questa donna qui
pietro bene questo a veder bene ti giuro
scegli l'aggettivo che ti rappresenta di
più fluido
scusami mi vedi liquido come dovrebbe
rappresentare qualcuno è l'aggettivo
fluido ma fai una persona essere fluida
e tratto perché ori cookin soul
cosa che non è un gameplay non servono
le cuffie lui dr timido folle viri
timido non leggono anche le altre
calcolo fermi tutti esclusivamente
eterosessuale davvero pensavo molto più
gay di così pensavo di essere tipo il 2
oltre 4 addirittura non proprio zero
questo ragazzina solo un test di
riscaldamento perché non era proprio
test vero facciamo il test dei gay col
serio domanda numero 1 accusa calre
scegli un colore rosso perché mi
vorrebbe scegli un bios e che cosa vuol
dire ah no è un pezzo di corpo singole
di ti piacciono le esperienze sessuali
consensuali con membri del suo stesso
sesso
never in quale città vorresti vivere
new york london per il san francisco
tokyo mosca
non so se non lo so non so se san
francisco tokyo nel dubbio san francisco
si è mai stato sessualmente attratto da
qualcuno lo stesso ma basta farmi questa
domanda se non ha senso
no qua dentro un sabato sarà ideale
nights with netflix
qual è il tuo vegetale preferito e la
patata zio sweet le suite potato rega
dovete assolutamente assaggiarle suonato
in america è veramente strano un sapore
però ci stanno un botto
preferisco la patatina normali quale di
questi è il sesso più sesso più spesso
zoe bell ma basta farmi domande su qual
è il mio sesso preferito sono gay e che
testa è un aero parte da new york alle 4
15 del pomeriggio in direzione londra
viaggiando a 500 chilometri orari un
altro aereo parte da londra alle 9 30
del pomeriggio andando nella direzione
opposta viaggiando a 550 milionarie se
tu mantieni una velocità costante
vorresti mai fare il sesso con qualcuno
ha dato ma basta no
il gatto not gay non sono gay ok anche
se avesse avuto la scritta pò gay lo sei
però ti piace comunque piace a patata lo
stesso non sarebbe stato un problema nel
senso che io ho fatto proprio serio
volevo vedere questa cosa invece no
proprio zero meno di zero la carota a me
fa proprio schifo anche per questo pur
fantastica famiglai perché timi
l'orecchino a destra spiego questa cosa
perché non lo sapesse chi ha l'orecchino
a destra che i gay portava l'orecchino a
destra questa è una diceria non ho mai
capito se è vero quindi quando mi vedono
nei video alcuni dicono i liberi che
questa è questa che l'ato è questo la
destra
questa è la tua destra poi non sapendo
guardare cose
il movimento così è questa questa
sinistra cioè non è difficile quando
fatto l'orecchino la prima volta e sto
parlando di cinque anni fa più o meno 45
anni fa sapevo che sapevo che
l'orecchino se lo facevano gay da una
delle due parti però non mi ricordavo
quale fosse siccome non lo sapevo quando
sono andato a farmi l'orecchino la tipa
mi fa permettermelo a sinistra e io le
dico no no no no la loro ferma con la
destra e la tipa va bene e mi fa
l'orecchino ad essa mi fa il buco qua se
guardate bene ce l'ho ancora quindi mi
ha messo orecchino destra solo dopo
averlo fatto
ho chiamato un mio amico nichi e gli ho
detto nichi ma dove se lo fanno
l'orecchino e gay che non lo so
e lì chi a destra l'ora e fa la sinistra
molto di tempo ho avuto l'orecchino a
destra poi l'ho fatto anche a sinistra
per un botto di tempo li ho avuti tutti
e due poi tutti e due mi sembrava invece
ecu di dragon ball quindi l'ho tolto
solo quello a sinistra vabbè comunque è
un pochettino di di effeminatezza cielo
in alcune cose in altri ragazzi spero
che vi sia piaciuto non sono gay anche
se guardo i video di mente bizet se
fossi stato gay ma sarei sbattuto cioè
nel vero senso ma le showgirl però che
vi sia piaciuto arrivato ha senso di
velocità mento mi piace anche per i soci
hanno aiutato né scrizione rischiate noi
ci poniamo da ragazzi
[Musica]